moi j'ai pas de sens c'est maintenant
parents j'ai vu ouais ben écoutez si ces
partis site officiel satisfont à la
planète est un thème canada
bonjour c'est fou hein dans l'autre
studio on avait quelques cas mais n'a
rien fait c'est comme ça puis si on
continue comme ça
ouais la communale bah oui et c'est des
caméras de meilleure qualité pour
l'indiction c'est important et là vous
n'avez plus beaucoup de boutons à
presser non je suis l'un tombe de voit
pas de risque de dérapage technique avec
cinq valises alors par claude venez
venez sur l'écran venez vous vous
montrez comme ça vous êtes caché dans un
studio de mise en ondes pour mieux faire
votre travail
bon on est très disciplinée elle a dit
moi je veux plus travailler avec eux je
vais faire un point mais on a hésité pas
à voir une caméra ça va bien vous avez
changé de couleur de cheveux
oui c'est très joli on pourrait
l'appeler madame ping ça va super bien
autrefois on faisait de la radio peux
pas mentionner la couleur des gens la
couleur des cheveux pardon alors autour
de la table ja oui je suis la maman
gorille alors je vois oui services
français vous savez c'est un credo du
canada international
marie maryse jardin qui est avec nous
bon on évitait mais ne vous en faites
pas gimeno bonjour bonjour bonjour il
manque un petit peu de café c'est vrai
on va en ajouter deux d'avoir ça va être
on va avoir du plaisir aujourd'hui vous
en reparler des quelque chose que vous
connaissez bien on sait qu'on va
vérifier la chose grave noir le jeu de
la grosse boule et on va faire perdre
des points certains d'entre vous alors
est-ce que vous avez une idée du sujet a
levé la mèche de vigny dit du sujet en
général
une copie électronique pour me dire la
vidéo qu'on allait utiliser mais je
l'est pas ou pas j'ai aucune idée avec
lord est ce qu'on peut les aider à
découvrir le sujet de la semaine tout à
fait l'image voit si on regarde ces
ensembles soyez attentifs fois parce que
et plusieurs cas cette question comment
se rattacher cette vidéo ok 5 images
premières images oui laissons mois une
passe une très bonne piste oui problèmes
de vision
la radio est en cours oui je les
reconnais des ondes courtes
l'ancien logo de radio-canada nationale
à nouveau brunswick
oui monsieur davos a fait les temps
smessaert transmetteur attend tout à
fait 5000 noms c'est l'as haguenau les
antennes de transmission
c'est quoi le sujet de l'émission
aujourd'hui la fermeture de la radio
mais là aussi les destructions des
antennes mais non c'est positif parce
que ça n'existe plus aux journalistes un
anniversaire
ce matin je pense et j'avais commencé à
écrire 79e anniversaire je suis mieux
vérifier sur la nuit avec des
journalistes
ça c'est encore et encore et rabon 1980
54 à peu près we dance - la danse mais
la crainte de 3 quelque chose cela vous
transforme et aujourd'hui un historien
je vous demande d'être attentifs de bien
regarder cette vidéo parce que je de la
première boule aujourd'hui il ya trois
jeux par émission symbole à perdre ou
total et pour le premier jeu on perd on
peut perdre combien de boules
ouais combien de bonnes alors y avait
foule à perdre on va commencer par vous
marquez poser la question pour tous
marie-claude vous participez on veut
voir à l'écran d'accord je suis là alors
aussi première question rom y avait et
il y en a des tilles de tours de
transmission avant leur déception leur
démantèlement
roh il ya cinq ans inutile de tours de
transmission au centre de transmission
de radio
pour guider votre est-ce que c'est à
cinq tours de transmission est ce que
ces bébés neuf tours de transmission
ça part un peu ambitieux c est ce que
c'est c'est 13 tours dans me2 trois
tours de transmission maîtresse bull ou
est-ce que c est d aucune de ces
réponses
pour moi c'est un coup aucune réponse
aucune de ces réponses procédé mais moi
je dirais comme réponse finale
va-t-on réponse finale oui oui plus que
ça plus que plus que plus que 13
ouais vous auriez à combien plus que ça
tout ce que ça vous iriez à combien
aucune de ces réponses nous incombe
puis on trouve un autour de vins vous
combien tour très bien on se tourne
c'est pas d'un choix de réponse donc
aucune de ces réponses mais 11
exactement très bien ni 5910 fraises
mais on suit pas pourquoi mais oui marie
coll avec mes médite le oui voilà que je
suis huawei est ce que c'était pas top
non pas 1945 que l'année de liversay re
de création radio canada international
on vous demande pas les détails c'est 13
tours la bonne réponse félicitations
avec le vraiment avec le huawei et puis
juste pour vous que vous sachiez là on a
mis fin au service de transmission par
ondes courtes du canada international
alors que le service web prenait de
l'expansion et c'était moins coûteux de
procéder de la sorte et on pensait à
l'époque et on le pense toujours
rejoindre davantage de personnes via le
web puisque le monde c'est digitalisées
numérisés entre l'avenue blanc et noir
notre affaire 0 et 1 blanc et noirs
absolument d'accord
alors écoutez je vais vous montrer j'ai
d'ailleurs ces tours d'un peu plus
proches et ses rites d'un documentaire
qui a été réalisé il ya deux ans qui
était fait patrick la prison ça n'a pas
été le blockbuster aux états unis
mais pour ceux qui s'y intéressent des
images quand même assez incroyable
présentation de notre invité avec cette
vidéo qu'on appelle le numéro de marie
claude
alors c'est filmé en 2014
c'est au moment où on s'apprêtait à
faire tomber ouais faire tomber vous
allez voir que les antennes c'est très
bucolique c'est dans un marais qu'on
appelle le marais le marais du
tintamarre notamment airs site à
l'origine de l'expression quelle tête à
marc bridoux cette annonce parce qu'on
n'est pas loin de l'acadie quand même
ouais c'est ça mais c'est très beau et
juste avant d'arriver là
ensuite on peut les prendre deux ponts
est allé sur l'île du prince édouard bon
si tu es geste magnifique dans le monde
entier là c'est pas loin de la baie de
fundy
ces stratégies que c'était la pauvre un
vaccin très particulier à hawaï ben
c'est si ça doit te proche de l'eau puis
un des jeunes sera ouvert les ondes et
se préparer au mieux une bonne question
à se poser j'ai pas de réponse à ce jeu
mais poser la question pourquoi ce
qu'imaginent en fait c'est la reine oui
j'imagine que c'est proche de l'europe
peut-être puis avait une ancienne cité
en 1935 que radio canada avait créé une
station diffusion je pense que pour
économiser de l'argent durant a naguère
on va saisir l'équipement et on va aller
à faire ça pour le service pour les
militaires c'était fini au canadien qui
est en europe c'était la première
mission entre les images sont
extraordinaires voilà ça s'étire et un
documentaire regard des pièces qui va je
demande toujours dit attentif à cette
émission c'est pour une bonne cause
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
hu est en train de tomber
et oui une des 13 trains tombés et baume
est ce que ça a été fait un vendredi 13
je sais pas on s'est créé il ya
tellement de bonnes questions à ces
démissions qui fait absolument invité
celle qui est l'auteur de ce film en
date dans christie banane christie
bonjour est ce que vous nous voyez est
ce que vous nous entendez de bonnes
questions à vous poser pour pour bien
commencer et je vous entendez bien aussi
super de ce que vous avez pu voir les
images que vous même avait filmé de sept
de ses tours tiré de votre documentaire
[Musique]
il ya donc techniquement tout va bien
nous parce que c'est du nouveau monde du
digital des foyers de gacé on peut pas
réparer facilement mais là ça ça va bien
aujourd'hui vous avez des questions pour
amanda vous ayez des questions quand
j'étais je n'ai pas d'invité maintenant
vous en avez toujours des questions en
fait la première question c'est pourquoi
vous êtes intéressé à l'histoire de
radio canada international auquel
souviens juste corriger une petite chose
il y avait treize courts mais ces
palettes ou qui était responsable pour
des transitions les tours étaient
simplement les supports les antennes et
laisser les antennes sont les tours qui
faisait les transmissions alors la bonne
réponse serait quoi alors il y avait
combien d'antenne bois mais qu'elle
avait levé 2 moi j'ai pas la réponse
pour les antennes y avait tellement du
câble qui avaient des tours puisque
c'était une suite très très complexe
mais c'est que les 13 tours et est ce
qu'on voyait comme un genre assure de
l'inde marc anquez sur l'autoroute
c'était ce qui était le plus remarquable
sur au niveau visuel mais il s'est
laissé par les tours qui fasse et les
transmissions c'était l'école meilleure
française karine bon mais quand vous
parlez de l'autoroute c'est quand même
tout le monde beaucoup de canadiens
voyez ça à paraître sachant que ça nous
avait même pas idée de ce que c'est être
d'un coup c'est grâce aux grands
terrains très vaste qui requis dans un
avoir vraiment majestueux au niveau de
la géographie décrivez-nous les lieux on
parle d'un marais je sais que des
espèces protégées dans cet endroit là
c'est vraiment très particulier
pourquoi scandale et choisissez marach
c'est aussi une question que leonardo
nous pose un peu plus tôt oui il est de
la question souvent ensemble pourquoi le
lieu pourquoi mon intérêt dans le
documentaire alors normalement quand on
construit une suite de transmission au
mètre à un mètre des câbles en cuivre
dans le tas pour aider la croque la
propagation des ondes de radio france
qui a bondi à allianz phare et comme
comme un peu comme ça alors
mais dans le marais à sac le marin de
transformer ces marais salés et l'eau
salée ça c'est un bon conducteur de
l'électricité alors il n'y avait pas ce
n'était pas nécessaire le conducteur
dans le sol
parce que c'était déjà là à cause du sel
de contenu du sel dans le marais alors
c'est un lieu très propice pour la
propagation et aussi les ondes radio
voyage beaucoup mieux un pardessus blue
alors le 6
1 alors géographiquement sackville
c'était un lieu parfaite pour des
émissions en europe il le nord de
l'afrique pendant le deuxième cargo
galles et mon intérêt c'était parce que
j'ai agrandi à monter je suis allé à
l'école à sac alors les tours était
toujours un parti du du paysage que je
connaissais et quand j'étais jeune je
pensais que tout le monde avec quelque
chose comme ça dans leur province que
c'était assez normal c'était toujours
quand tu revenais de halifax qui
conduisait chez toi tu voyais ces tours
et tu penses à je suis presque chez moi
c'était jean de deux pistes l'une des
places de forcément inquiété mais on ce
jeu demande est jamais qu est-ce que
c'est tout faisait c'était juste une
selectour éventuellement j'ai commencé à
comprendre leur position unique et
majestueuse et là j'ai embarqué sur 9
ans de didace projet incluant le film
dont vous avez montré des exemples mais
il y avait plusieurs autres gestes une
obsession pour un des signes raconte
nous un peu la situation pour des
résidents autour de sept sites leur
cantini à propos des deux lavabos des
frigidaires choses comme ça des toasters
vraiment intrigué au début j'ai appris
qu'il ya du monde ça coûte si tu
habitais à ses poches disons à
l'intérieur d'une de 50 kg ma messe
spéciale ont beaucoup plus proche que ça
les gens qui habitent est très proche
s'il y avait des tuyaux en cuivre
le tuyau à 2 de plomberie système crif
ça fonctionnait comme jean d'antenne et
là le lavabo pouvait devenir un genre de
l'otan lors il y avait des gens qui
entendait le radio dans leur lavabo et
moi j'étais jalouse parce que moi je
n'avais pas une radio lavabo alors j'ai
essayé de construire tout en lui ou
aucune électrique est de plus en plus
les gens de la ville de sacs commençait
à me raconter d'autres histoires de leur
frigo le toaster alors c'était pas tous
les jours parce que radio canada
noël et mettait juste certains dires de
certains jours dans certaines directions
dans un homme qui habitait dans leur
route de l'ua par cabine quand quand
même intervalle n'applique il y avait du
radio qui sont émission lavabo quelqu'un
d'autre qui vivent ailleurs c'était
quand c'est des émissions vers le
mexique
s'il ouvrait son frigo il recevait les
nouvelles du mix et marines oui mais je
me demandais ce que des gens qu'il était
surpris d'entendre des émissions mais
pas dans leur langue
euh oui mais apparemment la façon dont
ça se se manifester ce que je ne pouvais
pas toujours comprendre ce qui se disait
parce que vraiment un réfrigérateur la
boue s'est pas présenté alors tu entends
des voix
tu pouvais savoir que c'était des êtres
humains qui parlait mais tu veux pas tu
pouvais pas comprendre là et puis des
fois il y avait des histoires rester
dans le sous-sol alors dépenses des
étudiants venaient de chez eux après
l'école y entend des voix dans le sous
sol ils sachent que c'est le radio mais
il faut vérifier juste juste pour
certaines alors est comme avoir dépensé
quelques dents tombent et éventuellement
les gens ça coûte une heure puis il y
avait une famille qui me disait
éventuellement chaque dimanche c'était
de match par la prod de leurs
spectateurs il contrôler le volume avec
chaque fois nous on a connu laboratoire
de radio vous avez connu les tables les
la halle et la plaie à l'avant-bras toit
où elle m'a pas écouté nous verser ce
sont les plus anciennes du fait que bon
vous avez vous connaissez bien les gens
du coin qui connaissait ses antennes
nous on a connu les auditeurs qui
connaissait notre service grâce à ces
antennes
donc on à l'autre perspective et je sais
pas si quelque part on n'a pas au fond
le même déchirement au coeur d'avoir vu
cette technologie disparaître un peu
comme on voit dans certains secteurs
l'imprimerie disparaître à des choses
qui appartenait à notre jeunesse
maintenant appartiennent
appartiennent plus du tout au monde
numérique
je regardais vos images et je pense
qu'on va regarder la vidéo numéro 3
parce que je veux qu'on montre un
extrait de votre de votre film certains
indices était expérimental mais c'est au
niveau de la technique j'ai adoré vous
allez voir ça elle prend des caméras et
les plans de caméra et ça prend du temps
elle prend le temps qu'il faut pour
aller d'un bout à l'autre d'une antenne
vous montrer la ferraille sur la neige
l'hiver
et oui cette antenne qui rouge c'est
comme celle tirait un trait rouge eux le
prolonge c'est un peu comme si elle
prolonge et la douleur du deuil
moi c'est ce que j'ai ressenti en
regardant en fait la question et à la
course et c'était c'était ça est
exactement qu'est ce qu'on voit
maintenant parce que à vingt cinq villes
le tour de chaque ville c'était par ci
un parti de jeu portrait de la zone
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on voit qu'est
ce qu'on ressent quand on passe par là
c'est les gens s'ennuient des tours aux
assassins de leur monter un mandat vous
êtes toujours avec nous en fait je
pensais la question comme comme ça est
ce que
avant c'était partie du portrait de la
sont là maintenant est-ce que ça manque
les gens ils disent quelque chose mais
oui alors en ce moment moi j'habite à
montréal je ne suis pas sûr que nous
mais pendant la démolition quand je
tournais et juste après oui c'était un
moment très triste parce que pour les
gens de cinq ans c'était vraiment une
portion identité l'indication de hachey
soir je sais que quand je tournais la
démolition des tours cela a pris un peu
près quatre mois c'était en janvier et
avril 2014 ça se passe pas dans
l'urgence alors là je tournai et les
soirs je pensais il y avait un tableur
pour prendre garde avec des locaux qui
avaient certaines personnes qui
voulaient ce qui se passait qui d'autre
tu es quand on veut rien savoir c'est
trop christ mort ou alors je veux voir
je ne veux pas voir les images qu'il a
parfait ce qui était un peu sanguin il y
avait certaines personnes qui est que
moi on réalisait pas tellement la hanche
c'était l'espace et manon les trous sont
partis c'est difficile à cerner
exactement où est ce qu'ils étaient pas
ce que c'était il était ici il était
étendu au delà de 11 km de rues vraiment
une pousse chant détourné 115 à
enrouleur alors sur sur le marais qui
est plus bas que le niveau de la mer tu
as des tours qui sont 113 matches qui
s'éloigne au long d'une rue de 11 km là
quand ils sont partis
tu es comme hockey était l'homme est
resté ou la première ou la quatrième
langue et je viens de recevoir des
messages
hier de quelqu'un à saclay ou qu'ils
disaient qu'ils sont maintenant en train
de construire une grosse bingbing de
réfrigération qui est très très grande
crise autrement oui ça c'est la
maintenant dans notre paysage mais je
pense pas qu'on va voir du must algique
6 assez disparate en vous avez commencé
ce projet là c'est un projet
d'art expérimental mais au cours de sept
films
les choses ont changé et maintenant vous
avez en effet documenter le passage de
l'histoire car les les tours sont
tombées va contenu un peu le sentiment
après des années de filmer ça le
sentiment que vous avez ressenti car le
dernier tour à tomber ok bah alors
pourquoi les éléments émotionnels
c'était le premier et le dernier tour la
première tour je suis arrivée là juste
15 minutes avant que c'est tombé
c'était vraiment être gelée presque
manqué qui constate aussi celui que vous
venez de voir dans le parking note
s'étaient filmés de ces lieux là parce
que j'avais littéralement pas le temps
d'aller me déposer ailleurs dans le site
aux caméras étaient actuellement sur le
fender de mauvais dans le parking
un jour d'été comme ok la tour sa tombe
et moi je jallet qui constate trouvait
je sentis le hac tchad dans mon coeur
qui met les yeux d'un pommier jeter
comme ok ça commence là les prochaines
quatre mois c'était tellement intense je
me mettais juste sur la technique
pas de réaction émotionnelle mail après
la dernière tour quand tout le monde est
équipe apprentis moi j'étais sur le site
tout seul à ramasser mon équipement
j'étais sur le toit du building j'avais
j'avais tourné une panne à travers le
paysage avec tous les êtres retrouver
comme décor après une bataille quelque
chose alors je vais tourner ça au
coucher du soleil j'ai ramassé tous les
équipements qui j'allais portier qui
c'était le soir piste était tout couvert
de neige parce qu' il fallait que ça
tombe dans le livre pour que le malaise
soit gelée au kiss canne blanche ça oui
vous ne voulez pas que ça 5
ouais alors toute la neige et ses nuits
claires avec la lune et les étoiles sur
la neige a lancé très brillant mais ces
quelques moments avant que j'ai réalisé
que hommes il n'y a pas de lumière
mouche parce que c'est ça le show
qui était tellement linping est où
c'était vraiment la lumière rouge le
soir lorsque tu voyais il y avait treize
tours chacune avait plusieurs lumières
rouges alors c'est ça qui illuminait le
soir ces accords qui j'étais lunch ou
sur les lumières rouges et je me sentais
comme alors j'ai pris le temps pour
manger à travers le terrain ou dernier
tour qui est tombé et il y avait un
sentiment qui règne en deux sur la soul
est un peu bizarre parce que des objets
industriels et inanimé du métal mais
avait le sentiment qu'il ya une présence
quelque chose qui ne sait pas dire qu'il
y avait une sentiment que j'avais besoin
de la chose et peut-être juste parce que
j'étais fatigué et l'âge et j'ai touché
ce tour et j'ai juste commencé à pleurer
et après quand il y avait juste une
sentiment que c'est fini il n'y a rien
que moi je peux faire mon job c'était
des témoins et de préserver ces images
pour que d'autres ne pouvais j'aimerais
aussi et on veut cette si on veut voir
le film gratuitement c'est possible ou
pas pas pour l'instant mais il ya j'ai
été approché juste la semaine passée
avec presque pas de 29 et un coup de
main maintenant jusqu'au 4 mars qui est
lundi c'est disponible en ligne sur un
site de films de science qui s'appelle
la bosnie et l'abonnement c'est juste 3
dollars pour le mois et ça te donne
accès à que 1500 et nous alors dans
l'eure ici tu pour le mois de février
ils y ont mis mon fils mes os c'était
pas monter je peux juste une semaine que
c'était là la semaine là juste pour
traitement ça coûte 3 dollars et c'est
celle là où ce que c'est maintenant je
suis encore en train de scinder explorer
la distribution et et trouve une manière
d'une nature vidéo en demandent mais on
peut voir quelques éléments de ce film
sur youtube quand même oui il y a aussi
le site web pour le film avec d'autres
extraits sur spectre de showa point net
s'il ya beaucoup de photos là y aller
tous les deux
l'augmentation des photos des extraits
du film et la description d'autres
projets artistiques liées au projet
alors on à anglès inspecteurs offshore
wave et en français ces ondes ou ombre
des ondes courtes et bien le cas où les
ombres et des autres
très bien merci beaucoup un mandat nous
avons apporté ce témoignage maintenant
historique quelque chose que je n'avais
pas dans notre coffre fort ces dernières
années on avait pas vraiment de
reportages sur ces tours et grâce à vous
on aura maintenant d un témoin de ce qui
s'est passé merci beaucoup
alors c'était un mandat d'anne christine
je voulais pas trop pleurer parce que
bon ça fait mal
oui je m'attends quand on voit les
images on mangeait pas je pas été à
sackville mais quand même les gens qui
je connais clients étaient là ils disent
que c'était vraiment quelque chose qui
est important c'est la fin d'une époque
non quelque chose qui qui faisait partie
des gens qui travaillaient pendant des
années et déjà qu'ils écoutent et à
l'autre bout y ait des examens et qui
n'allait construire la radio ondes
courtes et ça ne coûtait pas
d'abonnement ça me tairai les
déformations moi même là aujourd'hui on
ça coûte rien et puis on pressent
également juste un bouton on appelle ça
la vidéo 38 c'est arrivé ce matin c'est
patron calendrier ça et puis et qu'il a
dit c'est nouveau ça a été fait
professionnellement c'est la nouvelle
application pour écouter radio canada
international en cinq langues
alors voici cinq ans qui nation de
l'autre
ça y'est pas disons pas mis de musique 1
je me suis bien amusé ou anti musique de
fond est ce que c'est la balade ou
non non c'est pour tout les sites en
fait est là où vous allez voir comment
est-ce qu'on peut changer on peut
installer l'application en 5 langues
différentes
ces français anglais espagnol arabe et
chinois là on est en train de voir
comment ce que navigue puis on fait un
petit essai dans chacune des langues là
on est sur la rav prochainement sur le
chinois puis vous avez toutes les
contenus qu'ils ont produit à radio
canada international dans les cinq
langues
en fait si vous les faites en français
en haut vous avez anglais puis
l'espagnol souffre et en anglais c'est
et français et espagnol si vous les
faites lesquels des trois langues
étrangères vous allez avoir anglais
français et langues officielles alors
vous pouvez vraiment les allées les dans
l'aude et c'est très facile puis à avoir
tout dans les bus de baudoin vous savez
combien de moutons apprécié et demi de
vie moi c'est plus compliqué calé sur le
web
ces deux abstentions ouais non je suis
toute ouïe m
censure exigée voilà ses bras là alors
si le deuxième tour des grosses boules
aujourd'hui combien de boules à perdre à
code et vous a plu combien ont perdu
bull ce matin je dois vous trois
relations qui continue avec les symboles
américains
marie-claude voulait apparaître à
l'écran s'il vous plaît vous êtes pour
maman la reine incontestée voici pour
cette deuxième question à ercis ont
parlé des langues
merci informant cinq ans aujourd'hui
mais au total 1 kg s'étale en 74 ans
d'histoire en milieu de langast s'y
attellent diffusé ou transmis de
l'information y en avait sept aces piges
je sais que l'italie était là dans un
moment donné
et
les polonais ont aussi alors sept jeunes
ukrainiens russes section pour haïti
créole créole ou alors est-ce que
c'était à 12 langues
ces lots pardonnez-moi b 17 langues
ces 22 langues ou est-ce que c'était
plutôt des 27 langues
bon je veux pour
c'est depuis ce but les débuts de plus
en 74 ans jusqu'à maintenant vous avez
dit combi moi en train de s'intégrer un
but mais c'était quoi le premier choix à
12 b 22
enfin b17 puisqu'il est moi c'est 22 et
des vingt-sept haut depuis le début aux
jeunes bovins de stéphane en fait
plusieurs fois l'erreur de répéter 22
alors je me dis que c'est peut-être la
raison dans ses serveurs
c'est unanime
ouais ouais alors vous vous allez tous
malheureusement conservez vous voilà
j'ai les années laquelle ça a commencé
pour certaines langues
à quel moment ces disparus j'avais une
idée d'une langue imposée je l'avais
pensé aussi oui le tchèque
ouais ben ward chaque set ça commence
par teachers stocks chaque note chaque
semaine j slovaque
ok je pense ça doit être ça janvier 51
et ça a été long à me faire ça en 1991
est-ce qu'on va diffuser en allemand à
la mort c'est facile ça commence pas à
puis je pense que vous avez tous la
réponse vous êtes si depuis quelques
années allemand oui mais c'est vous j'ai
pas j'ai pas de données concernant
c'est bizarre mais non l 100 km en 46
avec la seconde guerre mondiale son ami
sans f1 180 en quatre ans j'ai souffert
mais beaucoup beaucoup de langues il y
avait au début quand les deux de la
langue allemande
les annonceurs dans l'époque c'était les
anciens officiers de l'armée allemagne
et oui c'est nous qui sommes bien ici à
dakar la main d'oeuvre pas chère
une vieille tradition écouter n'importe
quoi écoutez est-ce qu'on peut regarder
à quoi ça ressemble à du canada
international avec les employés
aujourd'hui grâce à cette vidéo qui a
été filmé par nul autre que
merci pour
non non c'est un petit projet n'était
cette épreuve je me demande est ce fait
que je remette du rouge à lèvres pour
bien paraître à l'écran dans ce sera le
niveau b ouais on est au chaud ouais et
alors on joue moins ça c'est des
affiches
oui c'est un fait oui en fait quand on a
fait le jeu 70 ça tout de buildings
qu'on voit à gauche l'a souvent ils
disent que c'est le premier lieu des
rssi mais c'est pas vrai le premier lieu
des 6 es dans une maison d'habitation
doute deux à l'ancienne maison de
déflation à l'adversaire juste les
équilibres et ça commence à la maison du
patron et ben alors se sont fait le tour
des décennies vous allez peut-être
connaître des gens oui on voit aussi
nous là juste là
la quatrième ousseynou diop sénégalais
d'origine qui était directeur une époque
la section française est arrivée le
sénégal en 1974 pour les jeux de la
francophonie moi un soir qu'il racontait
souvent il est très fier d'avoir
découvert radio canada international et
les gens qu'elle en a l'air un peu plus
jeunes sur les photos et ça vous allez
voir on se dirige maintenant vers comme
dit c'est magnifique c'est un bon pour
travailler plein de lumière même si on
est tous sous sol on est choyé et vous
allez voir aux aléas port apparaître
maryse tout d'un coup dans ça y est
c'est le bureau de mme harris avec
thelma et louise qui est juste devant
moi là et ça c'est encore une fois
l'entrée au sous-sol de radio filmée par
marie claude simard cette semaine qui a
accepté cette mission mission militaire
est là elle connaissait déjà les sujets
de l'émission
il faut mettre quelqu'un au moins deux
rencontres pourquoi hélas un point puis
nous on a quatre il ya quelque chose là
dedans elle a aussi vu le film
aillagon c'est difficile à déterminer
comme en politique en lecture écoutez
moi je voudrais vous amener maintenant
vers le site web de radio-canada
international tel qu'on le conçoit
aujourd'hui tu entends le canada sur la
page de tintin
aujourd'hui une fois qu'une mission va
être terminé ça va être mise en ligne
cette page officielle de présentation de
cette émission qui a lieu en ce moment
en direct à montréal et on a ce qu'on
appelle consulter nos archives
aujourd'hui de ces démissions ou sur lie
au sujet des missions on va les voir
marie-claude vous allez sur le site
enfin le septembre celui qui atteint
d'être mise il sera en ondes
notre site t c'est un secret d'état
sur le site et on va aller voir les
archives les histoires à lire ou à
découvrir
quand il y en a une qui m'intéresse je
pense qu'on veut voir le visage aux
jeunes aborigènes d'entre vous avait
fait part il ya quelques années puis il
y en a une aussi avec philippe marsan
qui travaillaient de se taire j'aimerais
faire participer les éditeurs suisses à
cette semaine que coïncidence bien plus
si je me trompe pas il ya une
un site spécifique pour le 70e
anniversaire une site suscite dans nos
sites
essayez point ca ou vous pouvez aller
consulter des choses historique
auto radio canada international on l'a
fait pour les soixante dixième
anniversaire des sanglantes mariko que
vous avez le temps de faire une
recherche rapide pendant qu'on nous on
parle de ces cautions là il ya six ans
deux fils marc sens à l'histoire en
france qui dit écoutez quelques
nouvelles très peu aller coûte 10 films
mais je pense toujours à ercis donc ça
c'est un monsieur qui corresponde avec
nous il ya une vingtaine d'années il y
les ir tape d'aider des postes de radio
des vieux posera jury des lampes des
années de la pravda seconde guerre
mondiale en fait pour la saison passée
on a reçu un coup l'électronique dans la
section espagnole pour il ya un passant
qui entendait les autres groupes en
espagnol la radio nationale qui nous a
envoyé une vidéo filmant et qui est en
train de filmer en fait la radio en
cours quand la section espagnole fait
c'est sa dernière émission que ça a été
la dernière émission de radio canada
international en cours
c'était le dernier programme c'était
assez intéressant moi j'ai la maison
vieille radio ondes courtes qui
appartenait à la tempe de mon mari elle
a travaillé pour l'eau et metz en
afrique
elle est infirmière elle a aidé à mettre
sur pied des hôpitaux là bas et elle
avait toujours ses nouvelles avec la
vieille radio encore et je tenais à
garder ça et lorsque les mortes
on m'a remis parce que je travaille sont
sa médaille de l'om et pour moi ça
voulait dire quelque chose
non là la petite dernière l'histoire
en argentine j'entendais radio canada
international en anglais parce que c'est
comme ça qu'ils m'ont pas pratiquer
l'anglais sur les analyses on doit faire
des cours de langue à travers la planète
c'est un des services importants dans du
canadien national il ya quelques années
philippe marsan je reviens avec cet
auditeur en france lui nous écoutait
lors du 60e anniversaire de rc east et à
combien d'années d'après vous souvenez
d'abord en étant 14 ans qu'il avait tort
il ya 14 ans habite à 2005
oui et puis il écouter une émission
spéciale de bercy sur les 60 ans du
débarquement en france de nouvelles on a
vendu se trouvaient des soldats
canadiens un document d'époque et
l'écouté ça sur une vieille radio
d'époque
en même temps il y avait la sensation de
cette transporté dans le temps voici
notre vidéo numéro 5 philippe marsan qui
nous raconte cette histoire c'est bref
vous allez moi ça s
c'est touchant on met le son plein ce
sont les sons du canada et vous m'aviez
répondu je vais essayer de trouver des
archives et vous avez passé sur les
ondes
ces archives et ses archives et
réécouter avec un récepteur de radio qui
fonctionné pendant la guerre qui les
avez peut-être écouté à l'époque il est
dans notre musique sera un voyage dans
les petites anecdotes mais c'est quelque
chose
paris brisé
paris martyrisé mais paris libéré
libérer par lui-même libéré par son
peuple avec le concours des armées de la
france avec l'appui le franc fort cela
prend tout à l'heure
cet habile de la principe f
c'est à dire de la fin de la présente la
france éternelle
[Musique]
la fin mars en france il y à 14 ans ont
fait jouer la grosse boule une dernière
fois au 3e tour combien tout interne sur
la question 55 ans mais vous avez touche
ça va bien 80 points 4 mai - puis c'est
un poinçon l'a50 à perdre quand même
vous pourriez prendre une débarque et
voici la question
merci à d'abord vu le jour sous le nom
de service international de radio canada
sur le préambule à la question en quelle
année merci est elle devenue rci radio
canada international
j'avais pas je savais même pas qu'il
avait changé de nom mais voilà c'est une
question purement est ce que c'était a
en 1950
est-ce que c'est lb en 1970 est-ce que
c'était c'est en 1990 on va commencer
par marie claude
écoutez je vais vous annoncer que je me
retire de la corse
parce qu'effectivement j'en sais trop ce
sujet voyons il se vautre sur avec ses
100 boul
c'est la gagne 1 alors elle est
disqualifiée disqualifié nous gagner
gagner alors on fait tour encore ok
parce que à 1950 même imprimé
connaissait pas la réponse vous voulez
avoir plus de temps pour réagir
absolument moi j'hésite entre 50 je
trouve que 77 pétards non je vais aller
avec 1950 il ya 105 ans que je pense à
rené lévesque
qu'est ce qu'il a à faire lorsqu il me
semble qu'à l'époque on disait
radio-canada temps je sais pas en tout
cas c'est un jeu c'est ok c'est une
bonne écoute et il n'y a rien comme ceux
essayé dans la vie sain des jeux pascal
mac et peut-être mais je sais je sais 70
magie mais moi je tairai 70 vous a et b
70 personne n'a dit si 1990 non et bien
c'est bien dommage parce que c'est une
bonne chose c'est pas la bonne réponse
1970 ah ben bravo les gars ouais
alors voilà s'écouter juillet 1970 pour
être plus précis et ont été renommés
radio canada international parce que les
patrons disaient c'était nécessaire que
rci acquiert une identité propre
distincte du réseau national de radio
canada
bien qu'on était allé j'allais pas
complètement voilà service international
vous écoutez le service international
on a des documents d'époque
si vous allez consulter nous à ce que
vous avez trouvé le site marie-claude
par hasard dont parlaient les eaux
gimeno le site de 70 ans non non alors
fake aussi dans le passé elle a dit au
canada international au service
international noster sida faisait d d d
enregistrement des artistes et des
orchestres et les autres est où il
venait beaucoup de disques d'envergure
de qualité de qualité internationale de
l'aspect international sur les
enregistrements des orchestres est
encore quelque part parce que je sais
qu'au niveau des bibliothèques musicales
ils ont fini ça fait beaucoup de
réponses sont des questions sans réponse
j'essaie la réponse mais c'est plaisant
non non on en reparlera présidence de
futures émissions gelé tout comme ea
vous vous trouvez ça matin dans la page
de l'émission aujourd'hui très liés on
est prêt pour l'image de la semaine
normalement l'accompagnent segment de
l'émission avec une musique pleine de
tension attention j'espère qu'elle va
pouvoir rejouer pour vous mettre dans le
bain vous savez vous connaissez le
règlement une image comme ça que c'est
quelque chose qui s'est passé cette
semaine ça pète au canada ou ailleurs
dans le monde
vous devez deviner de quoi il s'agit a
pas de points à gagner ni à gré mais moi
je ne répond que par oui ou par non à
vos questions ok je peux vous aider à
vous aider
ok c'était au canada c'était au canada 8
puis canal anglophone canada anglophone
mickey qui pas un autre carambolage
non c'est pas un carambolage il a pas de
mal à ça fait beaucoup de questions je
ne fais pas de petit indice mais
quelqu'un dit d'accord à toronto
n'entend pas loin toronto et claude une
politicienne non pas une politicienne
dollars ça n'a rien à voir avec un être
humain très tortosa n'a pas à voir avec
un être est ce un lieu quand ça va mieux
ça a lieu ben écoutez ça a lieu plus tôt
cette semaine lorsque l instant une
carte une grosse tempête de neige à côte
au genou tempête de vent ouais vas en
verglas
mais je connais pas il y avait du vent
ce qui a contribué au phénomène
c'est pas une politicienne mais c'est
dame nature qui était responsable de ça
comme des bandages de se resservir hui
pouvaient pas circuler de paul ouin
quelqu'un qui part de sortir de sa
maison
ça s'est passé beaucoup mais bon c'est
pas le cas mais c'est pas des bancs de
neige et des bandes de quelque chose
la glace les rivières qui déborde les
glaces pendant pas loin de là chutes
niagara
c'est ça c'est ça regarde les images
dans l'école c'est vrai la vidéo c'est
vraiment des gros groupes là sont de la
taille de poids d'un véhicule à manquer
et ça a été soufflée par le vent sur la
berge et un autre qui passait par là il
a fallu la ferme est en partie et ça
faisait du bruit on a le son j'espère
que vous entendrez lorsqu'on va monter
le citoyen ça fait du bruit comme des
groupes là sont dans un verre remplis
d'alcool
la lézarde vous donne une idée de la
taille des glaçons quand même c'est
quand même impressionnant je suis resté
debout un ouais
puis voilà ça ça monte ça monte sur la
berge sait pas ce qu'est ce qu'ils
étaient et ce qui arrive c'est que à ce
point-là de leurs rivières tourner un
petit peu donc la glace
emmenés par le courant passe est proche
plus poussées par le vent et les
courants ça débordait comme ça donc ça
va être encore lorsque koné matin les
enfants voilà écoutez vous me promettez
de mettre le lien doit parler 70e
anniversaire
ouais on va faire ça on a fait un super
spéciale je me rappelle très bien on
avait en fait il ya beaucoup de des
éléments je te dis des photos on a fait
en haut à la cafétéria on a fait une
démonstration des éléments il est
relégué à marivan qui avaient beaucoup
travaillé à ce projet absolument voilà
je sais qu'il y ait là je sais pas bien
où mais je voulais trouver pour vous
c'est gentil c'est superbe
alors marie-claude on vous remercie pour
cette semaine pour ce magnifique travail
à distance vous avez effectué et puis
merci beaucoup merci merci à maryse
merci aussi beaucoup à on parle avec
tout le monde attendait pas la boule
je les remercie beaucoup merci de la
semaine prochaine bye
[Musique]